ganz herzlich willkommen das ist zdf
heute live heute mit dem thema corona
denn wir haben in dieser woche gesehen
die zahlen sind wieder gestiegen
ganz aktuell meldet nordrhein-westfalen
dass der straßenkarneval der
sitzungskarneval der kneipen karneval so
wie man ihn kennt abgesagt werden wird
und wir blicken heute abend vor allem
nach bayern wo es einige corona hotspots
gibt zum beispiel auch in der
landeshauptstadt münchen
eigentlich hätte dort morgen das
oktoberfest beginnen sollen aber wir
schauen uns an wie es heute auf der
theresienwiese aussieht und zwar so
links so hätte es sein können so war es
letztes jahr und rechts theresienwiese
heute und zwar mit alkoholverbot wir
auch auf anderen öffentlichen plätzen
münchen ist wie gesagt ein neuer hotspot
denn der kritische infektions
schwellenwert von 50 ist überschritten
wie die stadt jetzt damit umgeht das
soll am wochenende entschieden werden
aber eins ist schon klar
der bundesliga auftakt heute in der
allianz-arena bayern münchen gegen
schalke 04 muss nun doch ohne zuschauer
stattfinden
viel gibt es also zu besprechen heute
abend wie immer eure fragen bitte in die
kommentare und wenn ihr über die zdf
heute app zuschaut dann bitte hier unten
seht ihr es eure fragen an diese adresse
unsere gesprächspartnerin heute abend
ist professor ulrike protzer sie ist
direktorin des instituts für virologie
an der technischen universität an der tu
in münchen schönen guten abend frau
professor protzer hallo guten abend wir
werden uns gemeinsam ungefähr eine halbe
stunde zeit nehmen wir werden versuchen
erstmal die lage aktuell einzuschätzen
natürlich auch bei ihnen in münchen
werden dann versuchen ein bisschen in
die anderen europäischen und auch
international die lager die korona
anlage ein bisschen zu vergleichen und
dann wagen wir einen ausblick in den
herbst wenn wir mal bei ihnen anfangen
wie würden sie die lage dort im moment
einschätzen
also wir haben natürlich in anstieg der
infektionszahlen das hängt meine sagt
ist allerdings wahrscheinlich immer noch
mit dem mit den rückkehrern aus dem
urlaub zusammen
wir wissen ja dass zum ende der
schulferien relativ viele leute
zurückgekommen sind wir haben jetzt gute
sieben tage danach das zählt sich dann
natürlich über die sieben tage zusammen
und jetzt haben wir eine inzidenz wie
wir sie uns nicht wünschen aber mit der
jetzt einfach irgendwie umgehen müssen
die gute nachricht ist aber wir haben im
gesundheitssystem zwar schon dass wir
wieder fälle sehen wer mir über den
sommer hinweg sehr wenig fälle gesehen
jetzt sehen wir wieder erkrankungen wir
haben auch wieder aufnahmen in die
kliniken aber das ist alles noch in den
moderaten bereich kein vergleich zu dem
was wir im märz oder april hatten wir
werden das gleich genauer noch ein
bisschen aufdröseln und auch über bayern
hinaus blicken wir haben kleinen
überblick vorbereitet und jan frederik
fischer zeigt uns wie die aktuellen
zahlen sind seit beginn der pandemie
haben sich laut john hopkins universität
mehr als 270.000 menschen in deutschland
mit dem virus infiziert mehr als 9000
sind gestorben und der aktuelle trend er
zeigt zuletzt nach oben
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1560 mensch neu
angesteckt wichtig ist aber auch laut
lka sind derzeit vor allem jüngere
menschen betroffen von denen nur wenige
schwer erkranken und in den vergangenen
wochen neben die kogit 19 fälle unter
reiserückkehrern ab stattdessen
infizieren sich wieder mehr menschen in
deutschland am stärksten betroffen
bayern
dort liegt die zahl der täglich neu
infektionen mit mehr als 18 fällen pro
100.000 einwohner binnen einer woche
deutlich über dem bundesweiten
durchschnitt
im landkreis garmisch-partenkirchen
sowie vier weiteren regionen wird sogar
die kritische marke von 50 und mehr
fällen überschritten
und wie sieht es in den krankenhäusern
aus dort ist die zahl der fälle in
verbindung mit corona zuletzt stark
gesunken und liegt jetzt bei 5 prozent
die zahl der verstorbenen sank nach
einem höchststand im april und bleibt
seit wochen auf einem sehr niedrigen
niveau
frau professor prozent was ist ihre
erklärung wenn wir uns gerade diese
sterbezahlen angucken warum sind diese
zahlen in den letzten wochen so niedrig
also das hängt natürlich von
verschiedenen faktoren ab zum einen ist
immer die frage wer infiziert sich haben
wir wissen ja dass die jüngeren selten
schwer erkrankten kinder dann zeltbühne
so ab 18 gibt es ein paar schwerer
kranken aber wirklich wenig im vergleich
dann wenn man über 60 und sogar über 70
ist
und da wir im moment hauptsächlich
infektionen bei den jüngeren haben
erklärt das warum wir weniger schwere
fälle sehen weniger
krankenhausaufenthalte und natürlich
auch weniger sterbefälle sehen
das hat aber auch eine verzögerung also
die aufnahme ins krankenhaus ist ja
meist so fünf bis sieben tage nach der
infektion dann dauert es noch mal ein
paar tage wenn man dann am schwer
erkrankt bis man auf die intensivstation
muss und er stirbt man natürlich auch
nicht sofort also das ganze hat dann
schon noch mal einen delay eine
verzögerung im aber ich glaube die
verteilung hauptsächlich die wir im
moment haben auf die jüngeren und autos
sie gelernt haben die älteren und die
gefährdeten einfach besser zu schützen
wir wissen wir haben jetzt genug
schutzkleidung wir wissen auch wie man
sich schützt die menschen wissen wie sie
sich schützen
das trägt hat alles dazu bei dass wir
das besser handhaben können
nun ist eine frage die hier im netz
gesehen habe die ist zwar nicht ganz neu
aber die kommt immer wieder auf youtube
fragt ein user namens raff zockt weiter
steigen die zahlen jetzt weil mehr
getestet wird oder weil sich mehr
infizieren
beides also zuerst hatten wir einen
anstieg der zahlen weil mehr getestet
wurde
jetzt haben wir einen anstieg der zahlen
war zeit tatsächlich mehr infiziert sind
aber muss ich immer beides angucken muss
sich die absolute zahl angucken und man
muss sich die prozentzahl der positiven
angucken und wenn die absolute zahl
gleichzeitig aber auch die prozentzahl
der positiven steigt dann weiß man das
ist wirklich ein anstieg ist und das
merken wir auch im labor also wir
kriegen ja auch jeden tag mehrere
hundert proben geschickt und es war hand
wochen dabei so im juni die liebe
wirklich keinen positiven hatten und
jetzt habe ich jeden tag wieder positive
also auch rein praktisch und das sagt
jedes labor merkt man das wieder
nun ist es glaube ich so dass viele auch
das gefühl haben es ist gar nicht so
schlimm weil es entweder niemanden im
umfeld gibt der tatsächlich an cupid 19
erkrankt ist oder wenn dann sind es eben
jüngere leute im moment die relativ
milde verläufe haben
jetzt fragt auf facebook der user thomas
schuster
wie viele personen werden in deutschland
intensiv behandelt und wie viel prozent
sind es an der gesamtbevölkerung können
sie das beantworten auf das was kann ich
ihnen nicht genau gesagt werden dass
lieber herr schuster wenn sie uns sehen
wir werden das wir werden das checken
vielleicht kann man aber trotzdem eine
andere frage aufgreifen und zwar die von
frank winter auch auf facebook der fragt
wie viele erkrankten wirklich nun ist
die frage was ist denn überhaupt nach
der definition einer virologin
erkrankung wahrscheinlich ist wenn das
virus nachgewiesen werden kann
dann geht diese person für sie als
erkrankt richtig erkrankte es nur jemand
der symptome hat also der am gibt es
kann sich jemand angesteckt haben dann
ist der virus positiv da vermehrt dort
des virus der kann das wäre es auch
weiter geben
aber der muss er deswegen noch nicht
krank seien erkrankt ist ja wirklich nur
wenn er symptome hat und dann muss man
noch unterscheiden dann gibt's ja welche
die haben sehr milde symptome
es gibt welche der mittelschwere
symptome und dann gibt es menschen die
haben leider schwere symptome und das
sind eigentlich die die uns sorgen
machen also die die ins krankenhaus
aufgenommen werden müssen sind die die
ja uns wirklich belasten und dann
vielleicht noch mal zu der frage wie
viel prozent der bevölkerung sind im
krankenhaus ich hoffe es sind keine
prozent weil so viele betten hätten wir
natürlich gar nicht die zahl der
krankenhausbetten ist ja ist ja
limitiert und damit natürlich auch die
menge der menschen die man gleich zu
nicht behandeln kann wenn man jetzt nach
schaut wieviel freie intensivbetten gibt
es momentan in münchen dann ist das 0
diese alle belegt die sind nicht alle
mit cupid patienten belegt aber es gibt
natürlich auch noch andere menschen die
intensivbetten brauchen
und da muss man so eine balance finden
also die man kann sicherlich in kauf
nehmen dass sich manche menschen
anstecken wenn sie keine schweren
symptome haben aber es dürfen halt nicht
so viele sein dass dann die nicht mehr
vernünftig versorgt werden können im
krankenhaus oder das eben andere
patienten mit einem herzinfarkt oder
schlaganfall oder auch tumorerkrankungen
nicht mehr vernünftig versorgt werden
kann
da muss man glaube ich gut drauf achten
wenn sie sagen die zahl der freien
intensivbetten ist bei null und
gleichzeitig sehen dass dieser kritische
wert von mehr als 50 pro 100.000
einwohnern überschritten wird
wenn sie jetzt noch verschiedene andere
kriterien dazu nehmen nämlich dass es
kälter wird dass der herbst kommt dass
möglicherweise mehr leute sich auch
erkälten oder oder anders erkranken und
ins krankenhaus müssen gibt das dann für
sie anlass zur sorge anlass zur sorge
wird es mir es dann geben wenn unser
gesundheitssystem überlastet wäre das
ist es aber nicht das ist es zum glück
im moment wirklich mich und wir haben ja
auch selbst in den zeiten wo wir
wirklich viele patienten mit patienten
hatten war das nicht der fall
daraus natürlich schon so dass viele
andere erkrankungen nicht mehr so ins
krankenhaus kamen dass man operationen
verschoben hat deswegen haben wir auch
so eine art backlash im moment also wir
haben einfach viele dinge die aus dem
aus dem frühjahr über den über den
sommer verschoben wurden und die jetzt
alle nachgeholt werden
die frage ob es im herbst jetzt wieder
mehr wird ich gehe mal davon aus dass
das wieder mehr wird das wissen wir
jedes jahr gerade wenn die grippe dann
dazu kommt dass es mehr wird und dass
wir diesem mangel an intensivbetten
intensiv plätzen haben wir jedes jahr in
der grippesaison es also nichts komplett
neues was sollte halt versuchen zu
vermeiden dass beides in einer heftigen
welle zusammenkommt und wir dann in
einer situation sind wir vielleicht die
menschen nicht mehr richtig versorgen
können
aber zum glück waren wir bisher in
deutschland ja nicht in der situation
andere länder sind in der situation wenn
sie mit kollegen sprechen ist
oder in mit bestimmten regionen
frankreichs bekannter von mir ist ein
marseille
die sind voll die sind tatsächlich schon
wieder an der grenze wo sie sagen okay
hier es wird jetzt kritisch aber in
deutschland sind wir das im moment ja
zum glück an keinem einzigen ort und ich
hoffe wenn wir alle vernünftig da
zusammen halten dass es dabei auch
bleiben
sie haben gerade den internationalen
ländervergleich angesprochen und auch
israel angesprochen mit dem zweiten
lockdown die kommentare beobachte ich
hier gerade gelaufen eigentlich alle auf
die frage zu stehen wir auch vor einem
zweiten lockdown oder wie hoch ist die
gefahr dass wir auch in einem zweiten
lockdown müssen die würde ich aber gerne
einfach noch ein bisschen ans ende des
gesprächs schieben und gucken was in
israel gerade los ist und in anderen
ländern wo die zahlen steigen
nina niebergall hat das zusammengefasst
das kleine österreich meldet 780
neuinfektionen an einem tag ein
deutlicher anstieg der verschärfte
maßnahmen nach sich zieht bei
veranstaltungen in geschlossenen räumen
sind nur noch bis zu 10 personen erlaubt
in restaurants und auf märkten gilt ab
montag masken pflicht auch frankreich
kämpft gegen eine zweite welle 10 1397
neuinfektionen an einem tag in einigen
städten sind versammlungen an stränden
oder in parks mit mehr als zehn personen
verboten
auch der alkoholausschank ist dort
eingeschränkt in israel gab es vier 1791
neuinfektionen an einem tag zu viele für
das kleine land fand die regierung und
schickte die israelis heute wieder in
den lockdown nur in ausnahmefällen
dürfen sie sich mehr als einen kilometer
von ihrer wohnung entfernen restaurants
schulen und geschäfte schließen
frau professor peter wenn sie nach
israel schauen was läuft da schief warum
sind die zahlen da wieder so gestiegen
ich glaube wir haben aus den medien ja
gehört die israelis sind lange zeit sehr
sehr lässig damit umgegangen und dadurch
haben sie eine infektion pegel erreicht
er dann irgendwann schwierig zu
kontrollieren das gleiche phänomen
hatten wir in den usa
die haben so ein bisschen eingebremst
und haben dann wieder alles gelockert
obwohl sie eigentlich noch zu weit oben
waren mit den infektionszahlen und das
ist so ein bisschen das gefährlicher
wenn ich auf ein kritisches niveau komme
dann habe ich halt eine ausbreitung wo
ich dann nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann
wer hat wen noch angesteckt ich kann es
auch nicht mehr nach verfolgen und ich
komme dann mit einzelnen maßnahmen nicht
mehr zurecht und ich glaube das ist das
was wir einfach verhindern müssen also
wir müssen versuchen dass wir auf einem
niveau bleiben wo wir das ganze in
einigermaßen im griff behalten können
wir können uns eine grafik anschauen von
den kollegen die die die grafiker
gemacht haben und sehen hier den den
ländervergleich ich hoffe man kann sehen
dass das schwache gelbe oben ist spanien
und hier sieht man also im frühling im
märz ist die kurve krass angestiegen
dann wieder gesunken
leider verhindere ich mich hier in den
ländern als spanien und dann sieht man
im sommer gehen die zahlen wieder nach
oben und erreichen jetzt hier wieder ein
niveau das noch über dem liegt was wir
im frühjahr gesehen haben hingegen ist
deutschland hier ist die deutsche kurve
nach dem anstieg im märz auf einem
relativ niedrigen niveau und steigt
jetzt ganz langsam wieder also ist dass
frau professor protzer genau das was sie
gerade meinen dass man versuchen muss
auf niedrigem niveau
das zu stabilisieren und das gelingt
deutschland offenbar besser als anderen
ländern absolut das genau das was ich
meine also das was spanien märz hat dass
man wieder so eine richtig zweite welle
so richtig steilen anstieg kriegt was
auch australien zum beispiel erlebt hat
dass das wollen wir natürlich mich weil
dann muss man wieder überlegen muss man
nicht alle maßnahmen anziehen und
verschärfen so lange wir das so im griff
behalten können dass wir zwar ein
bisschen anstieg in den winter reihen
haben und den werden wir
was ich bin zwar kein wahrsager aber
nach aller erfahrungen die man mit
infektionserkrankungen grad mit
atemwegsinfekten hat weiß man das limit
halt immer im herbst winter wieder zu
das heißt damit muss man rechnen
aber solange wir das auf einem niveau
haben wo wir das jetzt halt lokal noch
kontrolliert bekommen aber nicht wieder
irgendwelche breiten aktivität machen
können und vor allem eben unser
gesundheitssystem halt nicht überlastet
wird das ist so das was mein wunsch wäre
dass wir da versuchen alle gemeinsam hin
zu arbeiten und das ist besonders ist
uns ja bisher wirklich gut gelungen muss
man einfach sagen ja ich würde gerne
noch einen blick nach frankreich werfen
wo man das gefühl hat der lock down war
ja noch viel härter als bei uns und auch
die lockerungen waren dann eigentlich
relativ moderat und und kein 180 grad
wechsel eigentlich und trotzdem merkt
man jetzt dass die zahlen wieder bei
etwa 10.000 neuinfizierten pro tag
liegen obwohl das land auch was das
gesundheitssystem angeht und die
bevölkerungsstruktur dann den in
deutschland sehr nah es wie können sie
das erklären
ich glaube insgesamt ist der deutsche
von seiner mentalität her doch muss ein
bisschen vorsichtiger als der franzose
und vielleicht klingt das komisch aber
wir sind ja schon ein volk was er so ein
bisschen obrigkeitshörig es und das
hilft uns in so einer situation anders
kann man das glaube ich nicht erklären
denn weder thematisch ist jetzt der
unterschied drastisch noch von den
ausgang von der ausgangsbasis die wir
hatten die franzosen haben natürlich
schon mehr urlaubsgebiete als wir haben
das könnte vielleicht auch dazu
beigetragen haben ich habe so das gefühl
dass im urlaub doch viele gesagt haben
er okay jetzt muss man vielleicht
einfach mal nicht so vorsichtig sein und
da ein bisschen mehr risiko eingegangen
sind
weil sie sagen wir sind ein bisschen
obrigkeitshörigen wir haben ja auch in
deutschland erlebt dass es viele
demonstranten gab die auf die straße
gegangen sind gegen die korona regeln
und es gibt auch viele skeptiker oder
verweigerer die zum beispiel die maske
nicht tragen möchten
dazu gibt's auf youtube eine frage vom
user mit dem namen meinungsfreiheit und
zwar steht hier in manchen kreisen
kursiert die auffassung das tragen von
masken lasse den co2 gehalt im blut
ansteigen gibt es dazu wissenschaftliche
belege
ich nutze jetzt einfach mal die chance
und stellt ihnen die frage in der
hoffnung dass die sie beantworten können
also dafür gibt es keinen
wissenschaftlichen beleg wenn wir das
natürlich gerade für radfahrer so tour
de france fahrer die gerne ihre ware
roten blutkörperchen verstärken müssen
so für die bergetappen wäre das ja ein
sehr probates mittel
aber dafür gibt es leider wirklich kein
beweis das funktioniert leider nicht
oder leider zum glück passiert das nicht
alles klar ist diese frage beantwortet
und wir können auch die frage von thomas
schuster inzwischen beantworten
wir haben recherchiert inzwischen sind
mindestens 246 menschen in deutschland
in intensivmedizinischer behandlung und
134 davon werden beatmet also das sind
die zahlen der kogit 19 patienten die im
moment intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden müssen quelle ist das rk ii das
robert-koch-institut der lagebericht von
heute das dazu ich möchte gern noch eine
frage zum ländervergleich stellen
sie haben wir haben die länder uns
angeguckt und man stellt auch fest dass
einige uns ein bisschen voraus sind etwa
211 bis drei wochen sage ich mal
und man da auch wieder feststellt dass
die sterberaten steigen kann es sein
dass wir von den jüngeren infizierten
mit milden verläufen jetzt in den
nächsten wochen erleben dass sich doch
auch wieder ältere menschen anstecken
und dann auch die sterbefälle wieder
steigen werden
absolut das ist ja auch das was im märz
april passiert ist die eintragungen wie
wir sagen nach deutschland waren ja doch
zum großen teil über die relativ fitte
skifahrer gewesen die also aus
österreich aus italien zu uns zurück
kamen und im gepäck ohne es zu wissen
natürlich die infektion mitgebracht
haben und da hat mir auch sehr niedrige
des sterberaten und waren ganz stolz wir
sind so viel besser als alle anderen
länder
was natürlich nicht gestimmt hat in dem
moment in dem es auf die ältere
bevölkerung übergegangen ist in dem
moment in dem pflegeheim
seniorenheime erreicht hat oder auch
gefährdete bevölkerungsgruppen erreicht
hat in dem moment liegt natürlich auch
die sterberate wieder an und ich
erinnere mich gut an einen 26 jährigen
patienten mit einer multiplen sklerose
er hat sich infiziert und war drei tage
später tot das ist also nicht so dass es
jetzt nur die älteren trifft sondern es
gibt natürlich auch junge patienten die
therapie nehmen müssen und die dann eben
auch sehr gefährdet sind
aber es sind halt viel weniger als bei
den älteren
nun hat hessen zum beispiel heute alle
beschränkungen wieder gelockert was die
besucher in pflegeheimen angeht das ist
natürlich ein spagat zwischen der würde
der menschen in diesen heimen die
natürlich auch kontakte brauchen ihre
angehörigen brauchen wärme und menschen
um sich herum und gleichzeitig vor
diesem virus geschützt werden wie ist da
jetzt gerade im hinblick auf das was sie
gerade gesagt haben der richtige weg
also ich glaube ganz wichtig ist es die
hygienemaßnahmen einzuhalten ich kann ja
auch meine mutter besuchen im pflegeheim
und kann dabei eine maske tragen ich
kann sie auch kurz in den arm nehmen und
dann wieder ein bisschen abstand halten
ich glaube man kann schon für sich
selber auch wege finden wie man damit
umgehen kann ohne dass man die älteren
menschen komplett isolieren muss ideal
wäre es natürlich schon wir hätten so
ein schnelltest wohl jeder der in einen
bereich das irgendwo gefährdet es
hineingeht getestet werden könnte und
dann vielleicht eine viertelstunde halbe
stunde später wüsste okay ich habe ein
virus oder ich habe keins und selbst
wenn er nicht genau weiß welches das
virus das ist dann würde er halt in dem
moment nicht reingehen aber sowas haben
wir bisher noch nicht und vielleicht in
den nächsten wochen kriegen wir da auch
von der testseite her noch verstärkung
so dass wir da noch ein bisschen mehr
aufsicht hantieren können
also das heißt das wäre eine
realistische vorstellung dass es
innerhalb absehbarer zeit solche tests
gibt die dann auch zuverlässig sind
die werden nicht 100 prozent zuverlässig
sein also man wird mit so einem test 100
prozent der infektionen kriegen aber
wenn man 95 kriegt und dann noch die
hygienemaßnahmen dazu hält dann sollte
man schon auf der ziemlich sicheren
seite sein und kann dann vielleicht eine
ganz gute balance finden auch zwischen
den bedürfnissen der älteren menschen
natürlich ihre angehörigen zu sehen und
kontakte zu haben aber auch dem
bedürfnis dass man keine infektionen in
solche bereiche hinein tragen möchte ich
würde gerne einmal kurz ihren kollegen
professor hendrik strikt höheren
virologe an der universität in bonn der
diese woche unter anderem in den medien
war mit einem
mit einer äußerung dahingehend dass man
nicht sich nur auf die zahlen immer
beschränken sollte in der beobachtung
der lage sondern mehr faktoren
berücksichtigen sollte den hören wir uns
mal wird es auch wichtig werden dass wir
diese faktoren also die
intensivmedizinische belegung die
stationäre belegung die anzahl der test
und die infektionszahlen bündeln und
danach ja das weitere vorgehen
beschließen bei alleine die
infektionszahlen gerade wenn es nur in
der jüngeren bevölkerung ist
letztendlich nicht so ausschlaggebend
ist für die pandemie sondern vielmehr
auch die stationäre belegung weil es am
ende darauf ankommt dass jeder bürger
auch die bestmögliche gesundheitliche
versorgung in den krankenhäusern bekommt
das hat herr professor strikt auch
hierbei zdf heute live in dieser woche
geäußert frau professor prozess ist das
was was sie teilen diese ansicht
absolut absolut das ist was was wir auch
im mai/juni schon gesagt haben dass wir
wirklich uns auf die relevant perfektion
also diejenigen die das
gesundheitssystem belasten fokussieren
müssen jetzt war im sommer schon die
situation dass wir ein sehr geringe
desinfektionsmittel hatten und uns auch
den luxus leisten konnten jeden
einzelnen nachzuverfolgen
ob uns das durch den ganzen winter
weiter gelingt weiß ich mich deswegen
muss man ganz sicher jetzt so szenarien
wieder durch denken welches level von
infektionen können wir uns den leisten
ohne dass unser gesundheitssystem
überlastet wird
auf youtube fragt manu productions ist
inzwischen genauer abzusehen wann wir
wieder zur normalität zurückkehren
können die entwicklung eines impfstoffes
wurde ja in den letzten monaten mit
hochdruck vorangetrieben
also ich bin natürlich auch kein
wahrsager
wir versuchen ja immer unsere aussagen
auf daten zu basieren und daten basiert
kann ich dazu nur bedingt etwas sagen
was man sagen kann wir wissen dass wir
eine ganze menge impfstoffe haben über
150 die inzwischen in entwicklung sind
und davon auch einige die es schon sehr
weit geschafft haben es gibt ja diese
phase 1 2 und 3 der klinischen prüfung
bevor irgend ein medikament oder an
impfstoff zugelassen werden
und diese phase 3 ist die größe und auch
längste teil der prüfung und es sind
jetzt inzwischen jedoch schon mehrere
sie mehr als vier impfstoffe in diese
phase 3 gekommen
also in die letzte phase der klinischen
prüfung die dauert aber natürlich das
sind ja mehrere tausend probanden die da
eingeschlossen werden da geht es darum
ist das ganze wirklich sicher auch wenn
man es dann nicht nur bei kleinen
gruppen wie in der phase eins oder zwei
sondern bei größeren gruppen anwendet
und ist das ganze auch effizient das
heißt schützt das wirklich auch und da
muss man natürlich auch in einem umfeld
es auch infektionen gibt und zwei sich
ja nicht aber dem stoff mich schützt
oder nicht und das braucht dann schon
eine ganz ordentliche zahl an probanden
bis man da wirklich eine statistisch
signifikante aussage treffen kann
und da stehen wir im moment also diese
testungen sind angelaufen aber die
werden einfach noch ein bisschen dauern
und dann müssen die natürlich alle sehr
gründlich ausgewertet werden die viren
an bild den behörden vorgelegt und dann
prüfen die behörden das noch mal nach
und erst dann kommt es überhaupt seiner
zulassung also ich persönlich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass das vor frühjahr
nächsten jahres der fall sein kann
aber wie gesagt ich bin auch kein
wahrsager vielleicht täusche ich mich ja
aber gehen wir mal davon aus dass im
frühjahr nächsten jahres sommer nächsten
jahres dann ein impfstoff vorhanden ist
da muss man sich ja überlegen man hat ja
nicht sofort für alle menschen auf der
welt den impfstoff und wir werden auch
nicht sofort für selbst wenn sich mit 80
millionen sondern nur 20 millionen
deutsche impfen lassen wollten nur da 30
auch für die haben wir nicht sofort
nimmt stoffe noch wir haben gar nicht
die logistik dann sofort alle
gleichzeitig zu impfen auch das wird
dann einfach noch mal mehrere wochen bis
ein paar monate dauern
also realistisch denke ich nächstes jahr
im herbst sind mir deutlich besser
aufgestellt aber durch diesen winter
müssen wir einfach noch durch dann ist
sie jetzt da die frage nach dem zweiten
lockdown wir müssen durch diesen winter
durch ohne impfstoff wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auch in
deutschland einen zweiten lockdown geben
wird auch das ist eine frage die man
jetzt auf daten basierend eigentlich
nicht beantworten kann
das hängt natürlich total von dem ab wie
gut die menschen mitmachen wie gut sie
aufpassen
auch von externen faktoren was in den
ländern um uns herum passiert ist
natürlich wir sind ja nicht komplett
isoliert hier in deutschland
davon hängt das sicherlich ab ich
persönlich glaube wir haben eine chance
dass wir ohne zweifel ob down durchgehen
und ich finde es extrem wichtig denn es
geht natürlich um die schulen die offen
bleiben sollen es geht um die
kindertagesstätten damit die eltern
weiter arbeiten können auch damit die
wirtschaft weiter laufen kann
denn wenn wir es riskieren dass wir in
einem zweiten block da müssen das würde
unsere wirtschaft sicherlich erheblich
schaden
wir hatten hier so ein kreis von think
tank mit auch wirklich vertretern der
großen firmen und die st das erste haben
sie ganz gut überstanden zweiter werk
katastrophal
und das kostet dann wirklich
arbeitskräfte und das macht uns richtig
probleme und das sollte uns hoffentlich
nach der jetzt ja doch entspannten phase
im sommer den antrieb geben zu versuchen
möglichst gut durch diesen winter
nochmal durchzukommen
nun möchte ich gerne zum ende des
gesprächs noch einmal die eilmeldung
oder die ganz geld aktuelle meldung
aufgreifen die wir zuvor bekommen haben
nämlich dass der straßenkarneval in
nordrhein-westfalen abgesagt worden ist
und wir wissen dass das nicht nur spaß
ist und wichtig für unglaublich viele
menschen sondern dass auch das ein
tatsächlich schwerer wirtschaftszweig
ist von dem viele menschen und auch
viele existenzen abhängen also auch da
wird es viele wirtschaftliche probleme
geben aufgrund dieser entscheidung
halten sieht es trotzdem aus
biologischer sicht für die richtige
entscheidung aus der momentanen sicht ja
ich weiß natürlich auch nicht wie dann
im kann man nicht aus wenn ich habe es
wird irgendwann januar februar sein
wie dann die genauen zahlen sein werden
aber es ist winterzeit ist volle zeit in
der auch immer die grippewelle kursiert
das heißt die chance dass die zahlen
nicht so sein dass man einfach locker
sein kann gelassen karneval laufen sind
relativ hoch
das oktoberfest hat man auch abgesagt
wenn man auch gesagt hat okay was müssen
sich natürlich auch alle drauf
einstellen wenn ich mich früher darauf
einsteigen kann ist es besser als wenn
ich das erste jahr später fahrer und ich
nehme an das ist das was auch jetzt
diese entscheidungen getrieben hat den
menschen zeit zu geben sich darauf
vorzubereiten
und natürlich ist das hart es ist hart
für alle
baustelle dass es hart extrem hart für
alle die irgendwo im kulturellen bereich
unterwegs sind musiker die davon leben
dass sie spielen können und das jetzt
einfach nicht tun können das ist gar
keine frage
insofern möchte ich ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht in der haut der politiker stecken
die sowas entscheiden müssen
das ist keine einfache entscheidung das
ist natürlich jetzt auch eher eine
persönliche frage als eine an die
virologin aber viele haben über lange
wochen und monate hinweg sich beschränkt
auf vieles verzichtet und das wird noch
weitergehen stichwort karneval und es
wird vielleicht auch schwieriger werden
wenn man nicht mehr so viel draußen sein
kann nicht mehr sich wieder in
geschlossenen räumen treffen muss auch
da wird es dann schwierigkeiten
verschiedener art geben wie zufällig
zuversichtlich sind wir denn dass wir
alle aufeinander rücksicht nehmen und
gut durch diesen corona winter kommen
das hängt jetzt natürlich wirklich davon
ab wie gut alle mitmachen
ich glaube das gute ist dass wir gelernt
haben wie wir regional und auch gezielt
reagieren können also wir machen jetzt
nicht mehr weil da drei infektionsfälle
sind sogar sofort die ganze schule zu
sondern wir sortieren die gruppe raus
wir haben uns auch möglichkeiten
überlegt wie man die gruppen so
separieren kann dass man sie gut
sortieren kann und dann eben nur eine
bestimmte gruppe nach hause schickt und
nicht gleich die ganze schule schließt
und genau so können wir auch inzwischen
ganz gut regional reagieren da wo eben
die zahlen höher sind also ihr beispiel
fußballspiele das spiel in münchen muss
jetzt ohne zuschauer stattfinden aber
die anderen bundesliga spiele können
halt mit zuschauern stattfinden
ich glaube das ist schon eine erhebliche
erleichterung gegenüber dessen über
gegenüber dem was wir ja im frühjahr
noch hatten wo wir einfach auch nicht so
viel wussten wie wir damit umgehen
sollen oder auch die politik nicht so
wusste wie man da reagieren sollte
insofern ich sehe dem punkt dass wir
natürlich alle auf viel verzichten und
die masken finden wir auch alle lästig
also wir auch wenn man auch den ganzen
tag tragen und meine mitarbeiter hassen
sie inzwischen aber es nützt ja alles
nichts wir müssen da irgendwie durch und
wir müssen halt gemeinsam durch sagt
frau professor ulrike protzer vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie sich an diesem
freitagabend eine halbe stunde zeit für
uns
haben und ihnen liebe zuschauer liebe
user ganz herzlichen dank fürs mitmachen
und fürs zuschauen und einen schönen
abend und ein schönes wochenende von uns
allen an dieser stelle machen sie es gut